Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to Ronald from
Illinois? Speaking of Illinois, let's go to Ronald
from Illinois. Welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: Hey, you. Yeah.
Hey, I'm going to work. Maybe you've got one
quick question for you. So we probably got
arrested. Why have you been so quiet about it?
Speaker 1: I actually like it, I think. I think
the reason Biden's being quiet is Trump and others
are already saying Biden's orchestrating the
entire thing. You know, Democrats, Biden, George
Soros, they're all orchestrating the entire thing.
When Joe Biden was asked about it, he just said,
I'm not going to comment. He is making it. What I
think Biden doesn't want is to make whatever Biden
says is going to be accused of being extremely
politically biased. People are going to read into
it that Biden was somehow involved or whatever. I
love that. Listen, this is law enforcement looking
at evidence and bringing charges in New York City.
It should have nothing to do with Joe Biden. And
I like that Biden's not saying a word the right,
by the way, Rodney. Ronald is triggered by this.
I saw a Fox News report the other day where they
said, look at Biden's just smiling and not saying
anything. Even not saying anything is angering
them. I think it's the right move. And I think
Biden's smart for keeping his mouth shut for now.
Speaker 2: David, thanks for that
question, man. So keep up the good work.
Speaker 1: All right, Ronald from Illinois, thank
you so much for the call. Very much appreciate it.
Yeah. If anybody thinks Biden should be talking
about it, let me know. I just I just don't see it.